Another practitioner is recommending mistletoe.
I am already taking about 29 other supplements.
Is this necessary with everything I'm on?
Just did a cheek swab a couple of weeks ago financially it is going to be a lot.
So mistletoe is, so if they're asking you to take a mistletoe supplement and oral
mistletoe, I would not do that at all.
That is not going to be a big benefit at all for you.
If they're asking you to do mistletoe injectables or mistletoe IV, I would ask them why they're
asking you to do that.
Let's say if you were going to the wrong direction and you were doing well, while doing mistletoe
IVs or doing mistletoe injections.
And be another approach.
We just switched up a few things with your cheek swab so I would just stay on that protocol.
You're not going in the wrong direction, you're not looking for a completely different change
of approach.
Oh, I wouldn't do anything with that.